okay so politico you remember a couple
of weeks ago vast
grief and rage broke out because
politico's playbook had asked me to
write the playbook one day
now that followed on chris hayes writing
the playbook yamiche alcindor from pbs
who's a far left liberal
she had written the playbook don lemon
wrote the playbook
after i did kara swisher who's a
censorious awful leftist columnist for
the new york times she wrote the
playbook
so i wrote the playbook because they
wanted somebody on the right
so i wrote the playbook and the basic
point i made in politico's playbook was
the entire goal of the left seems to be
to lump in everybody on the right with
the capital rider so they can then say
everybody on the right is dangerous and
ban them
right that was my entire point that was
the entire piece
people at political went nuts they had a
staff phone call with 225
members of the staff most of them from
the newsroom because these are news
makers
these people will cover your journalism
and crew they got very angry and they
shouted at the editors but that didn't
work
because the editors were like you know
what we're going to have a lot of people
from a lot of different sides of the
political aisle and you
citing bad old tweets from 2012 that
shapiro's already explained multiple
times
that's not gonna do it so what did they
do a hundred staffers decided to go over
the heads of the editors and directly to
the publisher
of politico and whine about this amazing
amazing people
according to the daily beast maxwell
tony who's again one of these sensorious
types would love to see nothing better
than all of the folks on the right
d-platform to asap
and always gets the scoop when far
leftists decide that it's time to
try to get somebody canceled so here is
what
what the daily beast reports more than
100 politico staffers signed onto a
letter sent to publisher robert
albritton
expressing disgust with allowing
right-wing firebrand ben shapiro to
guest author
one day's edition of the playbook and
with the outlets subsequent handling of
the fallout
one day i wrote a piece for politico
ah peace and a hundred people at
political were like
how dare you
now listen they can't actually they
can't cancel me over politico i don't
work for politico
i don't care i didn't write for politico
because i needed politico's money
and so they can't cancel me that's not
what this is about the the what this is
about is pressuring editors
into never having anybody who's remotely
right-wing right for their publications
that is what this is truly about
and i'm not even talking about me okay
first of all the attempt to castigate me
as politico staffers apparently have
been doing as a white supremacist are
patently insane
i mean totally crazy as anybody who has
ever listened to this show knows as
anybody who's listened to my speeches
knows
i've given like full length 45-minute
dissertations in front of thousands of
people
about how terrible white supremacy is i
did one at
stanford i think it was last year okay
so like this is not
a thing okay but it's not just me
i happen to know columnists who are
really really anti-trump like so
anti-trump that they piss off mainstream
conservatives on a regular basis
one comes to mind i won't mention his
name
he was asked to be a columnist for the
washington post
and then members of the washington post
staff realize that he believes that
biological men and women exist
he was immediately canceled nope we're
not going to allow him to write for the
washington post anymore
by the way there are columnists for the
washington post like eric wimple where
like you know big publications
don't need to give shapiro a platform he
has a place where you can hear him
i will just note to uh eric wemble of
the washington post i wrote for the
washington post in 2016.
i wrote a piece for them in 2016. so you
might want to talk to your editors over
there dude
in any case the daily beast staffers
were so mad they were so we sent them
a bunch of leftist tears tumblers
they're on back order because we have so
many people who want them we send them
some leftist years tumblers i wouldn't
want them
to get their tears all over their
laptops where they are busy journalism
all over the place
according to the daily beast earlier
this month
the beltway news outlet handed over the
keys to its signature news product to
shapiro a talk radio host and pundit who
has long been one of the most
controversial voices
in right-wing media thanks in part to
his incendiary comments about the lgbt
community
muslim black americans and jews who
support democratic politicians
the guest appearance part of the series
of guest appearances by political media
figures including chris hayes and chuck
todd
they're not controversial by the way
chris haye's not controversial at all
right i love how i'm a white right-wing
firebrand chris he's just he's just the
guy
she's the media figure sparked immediate
backlash and criticism from many in the
media industry
including within politico's own newsroom
but the resulting response from politico
brass was unsatisfactory to a number
of employees wow unsatisfactory to the
employees
wow terrible by the way you know what we
call
unsatisfactory to the employees here at
the daily wire
a job that's what we call it
because you're getting paid to do things
that are unsatisfactory to you nearly
every single day
it's called employment gang according to
multiple political insiders familiar
with the situation
the letter to albritton criticized the
decision to publish shapiro
claiming it had demoralized a
substantial portion of the newsroom
oh it demoralized you that's sad what
happened
what happened you couldn't report on how
wonderful joe biden's dog is today
because you were so depressed that i
wrote a piece for you two weeks ago
you fragile little babies seriously my
goodness
i'm so demoralized oh my god i can't
even every time i start to write
every time i start to do my job i think
of the fact that shapiro's name appeared
in politico and i just i can't
i can't i wha i need my i need the
ambulance
during a combative meeting on january
14th the day of shapiro's publication
the top editor defended the editorial
decision to irate staffers by claiming
mischief making has already always been
part of politico's secret sauce
the staff letter sent 10 days to go to
albritton maintained that matt kaminski
was the editor had not appropriately
apologized for his responses
additionally referencing an email he
sent to staff on january 15th obtained
and reviewed by the daily beast
by the way leaking internal memos to the
daily beast should be a fireable offense
should it not over a politico maybe you
guys ought to get on that
in the email the top editor expressed
regret for his initial response about
making mischief but reiterated that
publishing shapiro was part of his hopes
to experiment and mix things up
in order to keep political vital and
vibrant to its readers in response the
letter chinese asked all britain how
shapiro's extensive record of bigotry
can be considered
vibrant or vital because that's the way
this works okay the way that it works is
if you've ever said anything that you
regret
or if you've ever said anything that
people can interpret wrongly as
terrible and horrible and no good and
very bad this means that you must never
be allowed to speak
ever again ever in history it's a
i'm i'm glad politico staffers are so
pure man the woke mob either join it or
they come after you that's the way that
it works over there
elsewhere in the notes of their
publisher the politico staffers called
for a commitment to clarify and improve
the outlet's editorial standards an
increase in newsroom diversity uh so
it's just the man letter this is these
guys are going to hold hostage
politico's image so they can get a bunch
of crap that politico doesn't want to do
a commitment to clarify and improve the
outlet's editorial standards which means
we we want a veto on what gets printed
just like the new york times
has basically handed over veto power to
the pseudo-journalist and fictionalized
historian nicole hannah jones
an increase in newsroom diversities they
want hiring based on rays an
editor's note on shapiro's edition of
playbook so they want like a little note
at the bottom saying shapiro's a bigot
but we published him anyway we're really
sad about that but we're not pulling it
and an internal apology for the
management response to staff criticism
of publishing shapiro
despite the 100 plus signatures to the
note some politico staffers stressed to
the daily beast it did not represent the
overall mood
at the publication several of the
company's 300 editorial employees said
they hadn't even heard about the effort
or weren't asked to sign the letter
others said they were encouraged that
kaminsky and other top editors have been
meeting over the past several days
with newsroom employees and attempts to
avoid blow-ups like the shapiro saga
well
i mean i'm so glad that they've been
meeting with the whiniest among them to
avoid
the blow-ups did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional leftist tier don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity
hit the like button